welcome Tom but he did address us
properly yes he did it's Tom's mic on no
it's it sounds not yet is okay do you
feel that when you're talking to a dead
mic that good you can definitely see
Millie ate it yeah it's so humiliating
feel like you didn't want me here do you
want to address us again like this
greeting again you kept away how much
did you lose total I like fifty and
you've kept it all off pretty much yeah
I'm probably fluctuate you know now
pounds here and there but at this point
how much of it is to be healthy and how
much of it is despite Bert Kreischer ah
man I mean having the kit you know
having kids definitely you're there is
that thing you're like I gotta be alive
yeah oh your eyes yeah yeah yeah you
know I mean but also it but he is
getting fatter
isn't that does feel he's burnt
fattening up again yeah Burke's got kids
too though he doesn't wanna stay alive
for different I see yeah you can more
like CD back to drinking oh we had sober
October I remember dear which for all of
us was like okay 30 days mm-hmm not a
challenge and he was like sweating out
[ __ ] white-knuckle it yeah it wasn't
comfortable for him I don't think so I
mean he would be like it's not a big
deal but then you know he would salivate
as the end of the month was coming
closer right yeah yeah and in October
was a long a long time ago a lot he did
partake now he does I will say this he
is a wonder in the sense that you know
he was telling us I could definitely run
a marathon like you know whatever he
would just throw that out there we're
like no you can't mm-hmm people train a
long time dude you're disgusting
and you told him of course yeah and
you're not gonna do that and then he
just he called me and what was in April
I'm gonna do the LA Marathon next
weekend I go you're gonna do the LA
Marathon yeah we're like okay and we
were all Chad
behind his back uh-huh he's gonna die
right hurt he [ __ ] did it in one shot
he finished it 533 which is like a
twelve and a half minute that's a great
time for like for not doing that obese
alcoholic yeah yeah and then the best is
that so I saw him like a month later I'm
like Dan he looks big I'm like dude
what's up he's like I just I just gave
myself a lot of permission after in the
marathon like you know the calories
don't keep burning it's like that right
hey you know he's like yeah I've really
gone overboard right
since then we're like the marathon is
still what he will cite if you were to
like put pasta in front of him right now
but yeah I ran a marathon I can lose it
whatever I want
he's amazing though the fact that he can
drink at like he drinks and still
function and not be a nasty drunk and
then he's one of the great drunk he'll
literally he's a great drug he'll
literally live to be 95 he's one of
those guys that just his arteries are
thick and big and healthy yeah that's
right
he'll either be either live to 95 or be
dead within the month yeah we know which
option we're hoping for but help is
amazing to be able to do that yeah it
totally has been how do you run a
marathon no yeah I also have zero desire
to which i think is important because we
talked about I was like I like these
challenges sometimes we're like you have
to have the desire like the weight loss
thing we both were like yes we want we
want to do that on some level it will
better you guys it's not just for the
sake of the challenge I hate running
I'll do it but I don't
it's like I don't want to do it for 26
miles right were you we usually you did
you not like you I'm so self-conscious
about my gut like if I'm out I eat like
ice cream like a fat [ __ ] like I can't I
can't not obsess over it do you obsess
over I obsess I would say I think about
my physique and shame myself at least
every day yeah and maybe multiple now I
do have it's one of those weird things
where you know I've been I've been
working with a trainer for the last year
a good bit and you know I do multiple
times a week and I watch what I eat and
there's days where it's like I'll come
from the gym get in the shower and
looking in the mirror like hey you look
you look pretty good and then the weird
thing is like the next day you know I've
in my head
the body has morphed yeah and I'll be
like are you looking a pile of [ __ ]
today yeah it was just [ __ ] yesterday
that you liked it
it's literally body dysmorphia yeah
usually you do something in between it's
not like you'll always elite oh no I ho
ho
you're a fat [ __ ] you'll want to be
eating something that you should meet
and you get [ __ ] up yeah wife Carol
I'm sure she doesn't care she was like
she was into me at my absolute fattest
right yeah but I always was like you
yeah you always think women can [ __ ] us
for different reasons like I can never
[ __ ] a woman who is horribly out of
shape yeah but they don't care isn't
that weird though like and the the
biggest piece of shits that I've known
as dudes that have like no fat girl
policies we're like the fattest most
disgusting guys I've ever seen like in
other words guys who are like just
horrendous masses of mashed potatoes
would be like no fat chicks bro like
have you seen right but then the
flipside is that that guy will end up
I've seen him with a really pretty girl
yeah confidence does it's the attitude
the fact that he won't [ __ ] a fatty
they're like wow this guy's confident
like thank that same mentality is what
helps them get good-looking girls yeah
yeah I respect that yeah yeah I mean I
guess I just I don't know it's uh it
definitely doesn't go the other way no
not at all no not unless you're famous
if you're a big famous fat lady guys
will [ __ ] you yeah cuz you're big famous
fat lady but if you're if you're just a
regular one you want to be look at any
famous fat women that you'd be like yeah
that's not mine no it's my pic no even
if they're famous for you right yeah you
got it's got a I mean there's guys out I
mean I remember I had friends that I
worked with who were like really
attracted to really really big like
their prior afraid of being left that's
a fear of being abandoned or some [ __ ]
where you just like to go [ __ ] climb
on somebody to [ __ ] Holloway a giant
figure stick your dick anywhere it winds
up there guys do want it for their
confidence it's crazy right like they
want it they want to date somebody who's
less attractive than they are because
it'll make them feel more attractive
it's like when the way in high school
when when like the the hot girls would
always find ugly girls to hang
they would look hotter right right like
that's like we were talking a Moshe
kasher yesterday and he was saying that
like before he was married he would love
[ __ ] fat girls he loved it yeah he
loved it I can remember having dinner
with him a years a girl and him bringing
out like you never want to just get like
throw a bone Wow I think Natasha that he
wants to be like the hero or something
like that she was saying like fer there
was a reason for that that that makes
sense the psychological part always adds
up yeah you always look at it like on
the surface of like why would you like
this you know the person that looks like
this but then when you get to like the
psychology of oh you're the one you're
the Savior you're doing the nice favor
it's really weird I mean for me maybe
just cuz I'm just so basic I'm J like it
I don't feel like there's any psychology
it's just like she's pretty I like her
and that's it you know what I mean but
that's better that's a better way to be
but then you get into this other thing
of like yeah well he's got a hero
complex and he's got a saviour yeah but
you're just being your more stable kick
in hard for somebody like that that big
maybe he's one of those guys that can
[ __ ] a rock and wouldn't care I couldn't
do it right right no I couldn't do it
either I wouldn't be turned on I would
just be like you know and then she
probably wouldn't either but yeah I
can't do it are you more self conscious
now you're in shape because like or were
you more self conscious before the worst
here's the funny thing before we lost
weight the people like in public or on
social media I would say 1% of the time
they bring up right and so it's like
you're almost now you're finding out
that they all thought you're a fat
before well not only that but now that
they have like ongoing commentary about
me now
oh no like every week our podcast it's
you know it's downloaded but it's
straight it's viewed on YouTube hundreds
of thousands of times right and I mean
there's like a [ __ ] whole threads of
commentary you gained weight you lost
weight you look great you look like [ __ ]
yeah now they're focusing on because you
talked about the lie I guess right yeah
right
so this whole thing that started with
you making fun of Burt has really kind
of blown up in your face a little bit
yeah yeah but I mean it's good you know
the truth is like no reason I I always
named Burt and I even talked about joked
about it I would bring up Burt but I
really I was obsessing about myself it
was just right fun to throw it on a
friend right yeah I was obsessed with it
about myself yeah how much does he put
back on I haven't seen him I don't know
he looks like [ __ ] but I'll show you
a picture yeah from like from like is it
a flattering photo absolutely I think
you'll really really like this one yeah
this is him from a week ago and this is
him on stage in I think it might be like
Zanies or something he's just as fat as
he's ever been yeah he looks fatter even
and yet here's the issue now I feel like
he's lost weight right and then taking
his shirt off but he would now that he's
gained weight come on
it used to be like he was an in shape
guy with a big belly yeah now it's just
like fat and flab you know I mean now my
favorite thing is that so he shot
another special whatever earlier this
year
uh-huh shirtless the whole thing yeah
yeah and the last one was shirtless yeah
so I told him I was like you realize now
like when this one comes out you will be
known as as the shirtless you have
multiple shirtless specials right there
for you definitely like the audience
that will be coming to see you is gonna
be like that you gotta yeah and now if
that's going to extend into your later
years so now like that as you age and
you really fall apart they're gonna be
like dude take your [ __ ] County I
think she becomes that if he doesn't
take his shirt off then he's gonna be
like a fat kid in the swimming pool and
it's gonna be even more conspicuous that
his shirt he's gonna look even fatter
with a shirt on definitely because
you're gonna like you're gonna notice
the titties and everything coming
through yeah like that [ __ ] in Boogie
Nights Philip Seymour Hoffman with all
those shirt hug just dumb stomach yeah
that's my favorite China it's so like
perfect you see like it's almost like a
little toddler belly yeah like a baby
shirt is yes
perfect bit of costuming in that movie
yeah which is fat stomach so I was I saw
in your on your Instagram that you were
led astray via haircut the [ __ ] I get
you know as this has thinned yeah I just
got I'm not trying to do any maintenance
want to be like I'll just take it down
sure so I I would go to this guy to cut
my hair and you know when it was a
little bit longer and he would spend and
he was he's brilliant you know you've
spent an hour doing this [ __ ] and it
would always look good and then it's
like you know with our schedule with
traveling you can't [ __ ] always make
time so sometimes he would come to my
house and do it and then one day I'm
like I'm [ __ ] idiot like just by
clippers right yeah this is easy and do
it myself right so I'll shoot I did a
movie a month ago cuz I was by like the
wrong Clippers I feel like they last a
foot and I asked like the hair and
makeup what's the best clippers and the
guy was like get this I think oh ster 76
yeah old-school big thing he's like
that's what you should get I buy it I'm
super stoked I feel like I'm doing a
project when you're getting involved
with like you know like I'm building a
deck on my house exactly yeah it's a
simple thing but I get all excited about
it
I throw the guard I went with like a one
and a half guard threw it throw it down
and then of course you can't see the
back of your head sure so I just walk
into my bedroom and I go to a christina
and my wife and I said how's the back
look she's like oh over here you missed
a strip Mike great do that again then I
you know I do the neck and I'm like how
about now she's like looks great then I
go out I do two shows at the store
three days later I go to see my train I
go to the gym yeah as I put my stuff in
this lock box she goes who the [ __ ] cut
your hair and I was like what he's like
what did you do who did that I was like
I did it he was like have you seen it
I'm like no he takes a picture I'm like
holy [ __ ] looks like some [ __ ]
epileptic I think it's awesome it's this
like choppy diagonal line up the back of
his head did she see it just not tell
you she was like I I didn't
notice it you showed me in a dark room
and I'm like you got to do it asserted
do it myself for you lying you're gonna
run your hands behind it and you learn
to feel the texture you could see if any
is higher so you learn what about your
neckline I just do my neck with a razor
yeah plus I mean like if you look at
Jim's head structure he doesn't really
have a neckline it's just the kind of
all neck that goes up - yeah so so do
you believe her did she lead you astray
she cuz it kind of feels to me I believe
her
I believe her because her reaction was
like she got so blasted on that
Instagram yes
and people were like laughing and saying
this she was like I swear to God I mean
I don't know I've been like you share
bed you're turned over she didn't notice
the back your neck is all [ __ ] up I
guess that you don't look at the back of
your husband's head probably that's
right yeah do that right yeah I guess
but like you walk together he sure as
[ __ ] noticed it in the first five
seconds that I saw this guy do you feel
silly yeah I couldn't stop thinking
about it that whole workout right like
we're sitting there he's like do [ __ ]
dead lips and I'm like he's like well I
can't it's something about the back of
my [ __ ] head right now because it
looks so dumb because you want to go
home and right then right then yeah
right and then as you're thinking about
the fact that your head looks so stupid
do you are you thinking to yourself like
oh my god it's been this way for three
days everywhere I've gone everywhere
yeah I started thinking about the other
comics so I'm sure somebody had to have
thought something I mean I don't know if
you can see if you see yeah it's not
good it's very very bad very very bad
we've all had that don't I can usually
feel it you learn after a while just to
run your hand back and you'll get the
feel of it I love coming out here it's
[ __ ] awesome would you ever dye your
beardy you don't give a [ __ ] now they
did it for that for that movie and I
thought it looked so hilarious but
probably because it was such a departure
from right what I'm used to
they would they that I loved the
terminology they would say like the
first day they're like hey we're gonna
knock down your beard I go you're gonna
let that we're going to knock it down so
what the [ __ ] does that mean that we're
gonna aid you down I was like aged meat
diet yeah I'm like what are you trying
to figure out of age age I didn't down
does that mean older or younger yeah I
just don't know but knock it down and
made you down means yes say I say make
you look younger that anyone
use the word older yeah yeah exactly it
was all this like soft language around
saying like you look too old yeah we're
gonna knock his age you down yeah I was
like okay and basically I guess dying
would have made it like last much longer
so every day they would put fake tattoo
ink in your in my beard and it just
looked you know just looked fully dark
yeah and then I mean it looked I you
know you definitely notably I looked I
would say 10 years younger so it's like
oh cool but I mean I can't see myself
the people around you or like no what is
Tom doing he's walking around like we
know he's terribly died be related
there's no it felt it looks silly but I
mean I think like I know I look younger
when I shave when I trim it like the
bigger it gets the more the gray shows
and definitely looks older so I feel
like if I was really self-conscious
about looking older I would just trim it
yeah bears like you and every time like
a special comes out you know when you
get kind of like a flood of messages
you'll open messages on my phone and
it'll be like I love when somebody just
tags their affection or attraction to
you so they'll be like saw your special
loved it hilarious can't wait to see you
it doesn't hurt that you're sexy either
[Laughter]
I've never seen that message I feel like
I'd be flattered if I ever got that like
okay yeah yeah no of course you're just
like yeah thanks man but you're like I
don't need it yeah yeah you could just
be a fan of the comedy does it bother
you when you're onstage little bit about
private thirty percent of the men they
want to suck your dick in the back yeah
even actually getting a compliment like
any compliment it's the things you it
never you're upset you always are like
well thanks man right anybody I've told
the story many times it's a true story
years ago where a guy looked at my dick
in the urinal old guy on my home from
Rascal salad
I know guys really cruising URLs part
1992 and he looked at my dick in he goes
ooh that's quite a pretty one and I was
so he's the colonel from bugging me yes
it really had that vibe matter he had
that like soft like I see it and I'm
like thank you and he was to have it
sucked and I was like nah man I just
left it freaked me out but I did say
thank you what he first said yeah we
sucked my friend told me he was at the
gym where he lives
showering and that it was like one of
those communal you know showers hmm
and the echo you know the showers have
like the tile and he said a guy across
the shower was like oh yeah he was like
I can't I can't hear you and repeated it
and they get my friend was like I don't
know you're saying the guys came up to
him goes have your jerked off with
another guy all right boom putting out
there the crazy thing to say to somebody
yeah especially like Adam like you you
know that you're gonna see that guy gym
yeah it's like it wasn't a random right
rest stop again yeah but this guy's all
right well I'm doing lats tomorrow if
you want to [ __ ] you have to really
like blowing guys if you meet a stranger
at a urinal and he's it's a freshly
pissed penis that you want to suck like
you're just a stranger who's just
pissing out of it yeah
and you're like I'll suck it right now
they really I at least at least it's
like jerking off in the shower so
clearly thinks cleanest you're keeping
hands to yourself it's not a new thing
aside the concept but there it never
ceases to amaze me the extent to which
men will go like we're so depraved all
the clips that we play on our show are
usually just like sexual deviant like
twisted but like guys who are just
putting it out there right guys will
tell you demonstrate it doesn't matter
doesn't matter no a lot of them are
straight right a lot of them are
straight but uh yeah it's just guys I
mean we say we have clips of these guys
who are like just posting videos online
who are like I love [ __ ] and if you
want to text me or like that's just you
think does it ever work well that's what
I'm dying to know
I play their stuff I don't know
these guys give out these phone numbers
to the internet like do you think a
woman's gonna see you and be like he
likes [ __ ] then again the Craigslist
personals that used to work I know girls
that were on it yeah a girl I knew you
know we stopped [ __ ] a long time ago
once you update me on her sex life and
she would show me videos of guys she met
she would look at this one I'm [ __ ]
and they got a 10 inch dictionary but
I'm on the personals blenheim I missed
this website like there are real women
that go on these site it's crazy
I would never would have known if a
friend of mine didn't show me yeah oh my
god that really does happen I guess I
don't know I'm so removed from that that
I always imagined that women you know
your average woman would be like what
yeah women there lot of them are I
always think there I always assume it's
a troll there's been so many times like
for women for me to get like a woman and
know she's a woman they have to send me
I've had women sent me a picture of
their [ __ ] and then go hey what my name
next to it or hi Jim then I kind of know
but I always do them being trolled so
like how would you not think you being
trolled in a personal - sure we're on a
[ __ ]
fetlife or whatever where do you get
most of your you know just like a woman
reaching out to you is it like Twitter
you know Instagram or Twitter at one
point it was or a lot of email can make
most public easier to DM on Instagram
though that's right yeah I mean it's in
it might get lost in that folder but you
could still send the message you don't
have to be following someone to do DM
them an Instagram all right and do you
have is it is it exciting then like like
you know every road date do you see what
happens I have yeah but again as you get
older you know I don't hold I'm 49 so
I'm sorry no oh yeah
this is it's not it's not but it's not
for any reasons it's like I just got
bored doing this [ __ ] like yeah I
thought I don't sit around hoping yeah
and then there's too many people that
get attached for the wrong reason where
you start to realize like I haven't had
a real maniac in a while
I'm due and that gets scary like you
know I mean I haven't had a follower
like who you're on a string of good luck
ya know this end I ends sooner or later
and I'm like I don't need it at this
point I'm not horny enough to risk it
anymore
yeah you know I mean I don't need some
girl [ __ ] me in the hotel and [ __ ]
beam you know well you know you used me
shut up all right
twice having a public pervert for
[ __ ] 20 years yeah and your
I just wanted to put come on you that's
why you messaged me right well you
messaged me you sent me a picture your
vagina what do you think I was gonna do
you said a picture of your vagina with a
post-it that had my name on it there's
nothing hotter than getting a [ __ ]
meaty [ __ ] picture yeah sure you like
that [ __ ] she put her my name jeez
how long have you been married for 10
years 10 years
yeah now so oh so you were pretty young
we got in that relationship so you never
did you ever go through a wild phase
like were you doing stuff like this no
because I also wasn't like I mean I had
started working as a comic when I was
already you know dating and right okay
so I didn't I mean you know I had a few
but like that was before standing for
anything just feeling you met her before
stand-up or no no no I met her we both
met as like open mike rizzo okay and
then we were friends and then you know
dated later but I'm saying my my time of
being single and thrown it around were
even before that how do you like hear
Jim's stories and kind of just live
vicariously through them like that's
hilarious or is there any part of you
that's like oh you know what I missed
that phase and and as I'm becoming more
and more home a guy wanted to blow me in
a rest area and I got stalkers that's
not exactly but I love I love you know
you find that people and comics
especially have have like windows of
amusement things they like you know like
you can say [ __ ] fart to somebody and
they're just like excited by it they
laugh or they're like not really my
right and it's like for me sex stories
anything sexual in nature is always
either intriguing or funny or
interesting I just there's very regular
story yeah I guess stories all day so
it's not even like you're listening like
oh that must be nice it's just like
that's really interesting
like I'll watch every sex documentary
you know anything in that world that
that stuff always I find interesting
yeah it is funny here there's news is I
like a good a bad sex story oh man
nothing better right I love when my
single
friends that are out there messing
around have come home with a I got to
tell you about this chick I mean I'm
always like all about it right it's fun
to hear it is whether it's good or bad
but I prefer if it's bad like if there's
about to [ __ ] her and she [ __ ] puked
off the bet yeah that's great yeah
that's what it's like you know what it
is it's like there's nothing I never get
tired of like human behavior and what
people will do because sexuality is like
you should be once you not when you're
trying to get it but once you're in
there yeah that's kind of when you're
your most honest yeah right true like
that's really what you want and really
what you like and the other person the
way you react to each other and when
it's just a disaster that's a real
disaster
are you still hooking up with a
Dominican porn star no with what Mary
Jane Mary Jane yes you guys did it no we
didn't hate it yeah yeah yeah but Jim
says all kinds of [ __ ]
no I never had sex with Mary Jean all
right how was it it didn't happen you
didn't get a [ __ ] yeah by the way
she's had more personal time with Jim
than she has with me goodbye never
[ __ ] I would tell you factor he
definitely would I would do no you would
not I've been in a committed
relationships it's long before that I
maybe had a couple days off did Mariga
cook for you
no I've never I don't know Mary outside
the studio very well have you had her on
recently yeah yeah thanks to having run
all the time oh that's great she texted
me last night say when I sent her a
photo together as we were driving in the
car yeah she was she asked about Sam oh
and then she sent a photo back of her
chest and I told Jim to let her know
that she may not realize that in the
photo part of her nipple was expedient
offense but I don't want it I don't want
it to be is she still working this she
still shoot she's just porn yeah chances
and she dances but now she's also got a
hair salon did she like Owens it's her
salon it's her salon yeah Wow she's
actually doing really well she has done
I forgot that ever since Sam [ __ ] her
it's things have turn around I know
awesome man
just got to take credit for that it was
great that down why didn't I didn't you
[ __ ] that girl she say it was great
yeah I mean if that's the legend that's
legit but it's not that's not the way it
went down your centrist lover no no
now I'm c-3po a fox mechanical we have
goals here and we'll get to them and
then we'll be finished with it Sam as a
pet kisser I better pay I don't pet kiss
NATO you don't deep tongue kiss well I
don't really I mean you deep tongue kiss
a lot not a lot yeah but would you ever
let her go spit in your mouth I don't
think no no rookie yeah that's real
rookie should you think so yeah would
you let a girl spin your mouth of course
oh yeah so does JV [ __ ] yeah this is
starting to feel like the cool kid at
the dance Randy Cunningham I like to a
good deep tongue kiss yeah yeah I forgot
that you admit Mary Jean that time that
hilarious yeah tom was in studio is when
it was rude during the night show and
Tom was in and then Mary Jean just kind
of stumbled in like she tends to do late
might be other tip it a few back yeah
yeah I'm so hot yeah that was when I
realized that Tom liked sex stories
because it was like it was one of those
things where I was like okay I don't
really know Tom that well yet mmm either
Tom's can get pissed because Mary Jean
just takes over the room no no I was
amused and then I was like no he
completely you didn't mind that she was
chesty and now I didn't but I mean you
know I had to deal with it how long are
you guys in town for we go I'm leaving
right after this show I'm flying and
Stanley's tomorrow you leave bhakti
that's in New York
yeah and I'm on the red-eye tomorrow
mm-hmm you have a good what do you have
a good trip here amazing I love it here
yeah it's always fun if you were out
here longer you do gigs
no I didn't this time because we came in
and we just taped it I don't have time
yeah but if I want to come back next
time for like a full Sunday to Saturday
this is the first time I not here all
year I didn't come much this year yeah
but I miss it that's one thing get out
here yeah it's it's it's fun to do like
a week here we see guys that we don't
get to see a lot like I asked role gonna
comedies away and the guys that we'd
normally bill burr will usually come on
just guys that are not yeah yeah what
people are generally happy to see you
because you don't hear that often yeah
you know what I mean
like it's a it's a happy interaction
even bring a smile to Bill's face I've
been told that I mean he wears those
words but I
I would think that he wouldn't disagree
with you yes he wouldn't say it but do
you have to acknowledge you were correct
how long have you been out here for I've
been out here 16 years you love it here
I mean it's home now right so it's like
where when I moved I let's see I just I
finished this I was working on DC and I
went to my parents house in Florida they
live in Vero for um went there for like
a month and then I moved out here so it
was pretty much out of college yes for
the business yeah I mean I was
definitely certain I was gonna be acting
I never I didn't come out here to do
stand-up so how long did it take you to
get gigs out here as a stand-up well uh
let's see I got here in January I
started doing like bring er open mic
shows probably six months later is that
because the acting was not working out
no it's just that I was I was doing
these acting classes do comics would you
you're gonna be like like a like a sexy
actor no like a SNL gotcha
I thought it made perfect sense that I
would do it like in a year did me that's
how they tell us I was in New York they
didn't tell me you thought you could be
on like [ __ ] on a remote I was a live
remote Adele here no but then I got in I
got in with the improv it's like pretty
early mm-hmm
and so I started I'm seeing a lot of
weekends you know like doing that
getting some work yeah so here's the
thing once you like it's funny but like
once you're getting like 50 bucks to do
something like that you're like this is
what I should be putting my attention
into right so I would just focus on that
what you do before that when you were
like just working a regular job I was I
was a worked as a logger here logging
reality footage like transcribe I swear
to god I'm thinking he means [ __ ]
chopping down that's out of the industry
Jim and I are listen to something the
rock but writing yeah the raw tapes Wow
it's horrific so I did like just hours
hours and you'd have to log things they
want everything look so if you go back
now what was that again I lost it
there's a button and it goes like a like
an auto six second rewind and if the guy
went like mmm
you know like that you would go mmm you
know and they didn't have a voice
recognition thing that could do it no
had to be all by hand and is that so
they could create a database so that if
they want to do
storyline on the reality show we need it
because they manipulate they call it
Franken bytes right so they the guy you
say like I love Jim
I hate hamburgers and they want to cut
it I hate Jim you know they actually
will do that they need and I hate when
they need a Jim that's right Wow so yeah
and there would be a way for them to
almost google search a document to see
where exactly right I can't relate a
storyline that way that's amazing though
that they would have you do it by hand
and what do they do with three people
are talking at once dude it mean you
know we had six people at a station
transcribing 24 hours a day so we would
do day shift
night shift overnights like it was real
[ __ ] now they don't do that at all
anymore I'm sure they don't but I
actually don't know I've been so far out
of it but they might depending on how
reliable they want it to be because
voice recognize
like half the time the subtitles are
wrong well maybe they have somebody
though maybe they do a voice
transcription and then they have
somebody just watch it and listen and ya
do Corrections that will be easier but
those are different services to you know
transcription right is internal by the
production closed captioning you're
right is external and subtitles is this
totally separate well that's amazing so
did you ever get sick and tired of just
watching it oh my god dude
and I would did I did the first day's an
extreme makeover oh so we would have to
do people get plastic surgery raw camera
footage before the blurs or anything
yeah and like just that dude getting a
facelift cutting a face up and jabbing
[ __ ] a metal like you know it's like a
crowbar into their face and you just
you'd have to watch it in case something
happens or it said you know you'd have
to just watch that whole tape so how
long would you be like how would you
like you have to write Frank Larry used
to write their names there's a way to do
one what like a 1 there was yeah I think
there was like auto once you wrote
somebody that that could come up again
but it was brutal man it was how many
hours a day when it started I think I
was uh you know probably getting I was
probably doing 10-hour shifts or so Oh
God
so you're sitting there just reading
writing this [ __ ] and listening for it
and have to go back and keep listening
if you
catch it yeah go back in the right and
and then you'd have like a supervisor
but like you only went through like
three tapes today you really got to step
it up you know and then I got that job
remember I wasn't supervising the
trailers and I remember I thought that
that was like like a real job I've made
it yes what I'm gonna do
how many hours of transcription can you
do a day I can't really remember
actually the 10-hour shift cuz you do a
one-hour show well you could you would
do a/b tapes
imitates yes I'm getting raw tapes
obviously what you would hope for and
weird b-roll tapes you couldn't really
pick cuz like all sudden you'd pop in a
tape and it would just be like shot of
the beach and it'd just be a running
tape so you'd be like shot on the beach
and like you just wait until the frame
changed so you made that way you'd be
like oh this is great you can't
fast-forward it but you know you're a
lot to just kind of zone out yeah you
can zone out as long as it you know sit
there and but then like if it was a
heavily you know heavy banter
you know dialogue of people arguing
talking those would take you'd have to
keep going back you ever tried to switch
a tape like when nobody was looking if
you put a tape in and see like all this
talk or like oh hell yeah of course he's
put in another one good you roll tape
did everyone want to be role of course
that was considered a gem in every walk
of life every job there are these little
[ __ ] things that people want that
make their lives easier yeah like you
would never think when you watch a
reality show some [ __ ] guy had to
transcribe this but the b-roll Beach
footage is the [ __ ] it's the [ __ ] yeah
that's what they look for I remember
peeing on a on a production out here
where it was just you know menial PA
[ __ ] for people that listening don't
know it's like your production assistant
you do anything right pick that up
get that guy coffee up drive that over
here so it's like it's like being like a
little workhorse right a production and
I remember this guy who was much older
was like oh so you knew I'm like yeah
he's like all right tell you a couple
secrets he's like what you do is see
this like rope here there's through
these cables see what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna I'm gonna wind them up I'll
lay them over here and then I'll pull
them back out
wind him up again see what happens is
it'll look like I'm doing something and
no one will ask me to do something and
he was like so serious you know he was
like he was trying to help me out he's
right the key to this is to look like
you're too busy to do real [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah thanks man thanks this guy was
like that was like so now I know how to
be a PA when I'm 60 keep it look like
I'm doing stuff is that translate it
into your personal life like when like
you know your wife is taking care of the
kid or something and you have to like
figure out how to like you just pick up
a shoe everyone has their moments right
yeah I mean you ought you want to be
helpful and involved but yeah there are
times when you're like I'm kind of
[ __ ] doing something right now you
know ya praying that she doesn't ask
what are you doing but it is kind of
that thing where it's like you could be
like just looking at big tits and you're
like I'm saying an email I gotta get
this worked out white I'm gonna get
[ __ ] I gotta piss did badly okay you
couldn't take another break you're
pissing on this trip it's crazy
completely out of control I piss a lot
no it's way more than enough but
drinking a lot of coffee here it's out
of control I piss once an hour
way more than once an hour the fact that
it bothers you is what amuses me the
most I mean it's it's insane I do pay a
lot we have any we have not been on the
air an hour since he last appeal art
that much I have a good clean system
everything out literally I drink nothing
but water and coffee yeah me too so I
guess yeah we get to the studio the
other day I remember yesterday or what
and we're about to go on he pisses when
we get there he comes to the studio
we're in the studio for five minutes
he's like all right let me just piss
before you know I think it's such a
psychological thing like I think my
bladders never empty yes
like I I don't like being I was like
[ __ ] I can't piss I have that thing to
wear since I like I said I do drink a
lot of water and coffee if I'm at the
club store or something and it's like
alright I'm gonna go home I stopped and
I'm like do I have to pee is it even a
little bit yeah because I start to panic
about being on the road and having to
pee just standing over the toilet
lightly touching my nipple to roll
like me another pissed it's horrible I
mean how far away is your place from the
store no it's like 25 30 minutes I don't
care if like your bladders fold to the
brim you can hold it frickin you can you
know what I'm like I don't want to I
comfy
that's what happened to see you know you
have a good life when you're just
avoiding little discomfort Yeah right
like you don't have me like I don't want
to I don't want to have to piss
I want to piss now yeah those are my
issues I think when you're gonna piss
yeah
well Jim doesn't have that issue because
he goes every I'd say every 25 do you
know who else pisses a lot who ozzy
osbourne he's an older guy certainly he
is all right how does he do it how does
he do his show well I've heard he will
piss his pants then just dump water
himself Jesus Mart and there's a little
area for Ozzy and like when there's a
drum solo so he can piss to every guest
- that'd be great if you could figure
out a punchline in your act where you
have to pour water all over yourself and
that way you could piss on yourself so
grave remember being in high school in
football and having you know the pants
are like a whole procedure to put on
mm-hmm and being out there and just
being like I'm just gonna piss on myself
and would you yeah I did a couple times
when you were playing sports
yeah yeah and like you know high school
football but like could you stink
afterwards anyway you do but then
usually someone will be like come the
[ __ ] on maybe somebody we're not I mean
when it was like hey it's you know if
it's right before halftime you like I'm
about to be in the locker room but if it
was like you know middle the first
quarter you're like I'm not [ __ ]
getting out of here that would drive me
crazy how what a guys doing have to piss
I know that in the in the NFL like you
know obviously it's a whole different
thing a lot of times people will
surround someone or they'll throw up the
tent you know they have those those
mobile tents uh-huh and guys will even
sometimes you think someone's getting an
injury check out and they're just taking
a piss really yeah but there to lift a
cop what a nightmare that must be yes
between play and also like that is a
whole procedure those pants like if you
piss your pants in that don't like
everything's all packed in so tightly
isn't there just piss like right on top
of you ever it's mean it's just you're
if you're if you're playing you know one
thing if you're not playing but you're
just like so covering sweat it's all
yeah yeah yeah do you think those guys
don't piss themselves the NFL probably
for sure yeah I would imagine yeah yeah
some guys out there just don't care
there's some real savages you know like
some of those dudes are real crazy real
crazy they are
yeah I heard Larry Allen Tyson Walter
was a buddy why he's to play for the
Dallas and he said Larry Allen we just
[ __ ] spit tobacco on his [ __ ]
floor in the pit in his Mercedes I mean
those guys are crazy I hope that's true
I love Larry Allen the awesome yeah I
mean and I felt like some of the guys
who could do like really combat in
violent sports UFC guys yeah NFL guys
they're not normal you know so some of
them get are pretty normal I know a
couple guys that you know you have to
pull it out of them that they're [ __ ]
NFL guys you know I mean like yeah
they're so down-to-earth but a lot of
them are I mean obviously there's your
flamboyant showy types some of them have
like real warrior mentality
aggression all the time and why are so
good higher level of discomfort like
they they're they're a level before
discomfort makes them react is very high
yeah they used to be injured right so
for me just comfortably having tinkle on
my leg yeah but if you're you know used
to being kicked in the face a little
pissin gonna kill you you see those guys
[ __ ] fingers pointing in every
direction yeah even getting fixed no I
don't care
yeah hockey oh my god oh my god [ __ ]
six teeth left yeah even bigger like I'm
in like goalies goalies is a way bigger
ordeal than football players imagine
imagine you put your thing on the
wishlist the piss is the first quarter
you [ __ ] I met goalies are [ __ ]
themselves out there I know a kid in
high school who's [ __ ] his pants on
a football team on the football team
yeah min game mid get he care he did not
but coaches flipped out when he didn't
he didn't care he was like he did it
thought it was funny he also was like
crazy he was kind of crazy yeah yeah and
like could you see it like are you
wearing white I wasn't in that game okay
he was like at the neighboring I knew a
lot of people that knew him they
everyone's talking about he's [ __ ]
during the game and was like you know
piling on people and yes and like just
being crazy that would bother me so much
feeling you ever feel cool when you
after you [ __ ] your pants when it cools
you can feel it against your underpants
the terrible feeling
I never felt that you know she pants not
since I was a very small child is this
that's a no-no I mean that's it there
was a little kid no when does a kid I
guess
Moore's law Sam you [ __ ] your pants week
ago sure as an adult you should do one
store well to be honest it does Oh
grounded I was like a hobby like as a
thing like you know what I haven't done
this and do it on the red-eye smart
she's on the way home yeah
would you [ __ ] your pants before the
flight for a million dollars yeah yes I
would a million a million dollars yeah I
mean that yeah I wouldn't even really
cash in a briefcase yeah yeah sit your
own [ __ ] for seven hours yeah I'd be
okay with that
me too what if it was like real mushy
that's my problem you know what I mean
like that's I have to deal with the fact
that that's my diet yeah yeah do you
take mushy shits I have not regularly
not all the time what's your normal [ __ ]
like pretty water coming yeah you ever
see like no it's it's it's pretty good
considering my diet is not good what is
your diet I eat a lot of like I drink
soda eat fast food like yeah yeah very
unhealthy very unhealthy gonna stop that
I know you know I I'd like to say yes
but I don't think so you'll stop when
you like physically start to break down
yeah whatever right when a doctor is
like no no no no this isn't like you
know you better stop like you're gonna
die then I'll be like okay I won't do
that at all anymore
like you know just be honest a lot of
[ __ ] not literally but yeah yeah yeah
yeah garbage diet 100% I gotta piss
he's been saying it for [ __ ] tracking
all right we'll take a break
Tom Segura you know any gig come up yeah
I just added Boise Sacramento Fresno and
Bakersfield you all just went on sale
and by the way Tom Segura has some of
the best flyers in the business I keep
seeing a pop up on social media
oh yeah that I have some good artists
make yes yeah yeah so you can follow uh
Tom Segura all across Twitter and
Instagram and all that right yes sir
cool man and keep your eyes open chip
podcast live shows for Boston and Long
Island
September 1451 sale this Monday morning
yes well I hope people come well yeah
we'll be back
I feel much better good you got it all
around yes I'll do you ever do a doll we
would hang out with Tom Segura of course
do you ever do a double piss will you
pee and then walk out you like there's
more in there oh yeah right back in
really yeah or what about the you sit
down P dump then you're like all right
already
oh there's a whole second wave of pee
here yeah our second wave of [ __ ] I love
that when you stand up and you can feel
like what happened is it's like a house
of cards am i Collin I've Nev knocked
out the one and then the other half has
come down yeah I forgot we haven't done
that in a while but we were going
through a period of time for a little
bit where multiple guests that we're
coming at Jim kept being late to come
back to the show because he was having
elongated [ __ ]
I was shitty I think a wildest [ __ ] like
I like I look good
it's a [ __ ] thing like yeah like I
remember like I think Judd Apatow came
in yeah I was [ __ ] and I was like
you know Jim's here he's he's [ __ ]
but he'll be back and I was like okay
you know it's really one of the
pleasures though that you should enjoy
in life it's something that you know it
transcends all socio-economic levels and
right like really enjoying your movement
I don't see what's wrong with that isn't
it crazy people had [ __ ] quick some guys
walk in there and they walk out like I
just dropped a deuce let's go home what
of Christina's friends came over and all
the guy girl and goes you know like
magazines in your bathroom and we were
like yeah why we're like to read while
you should write she was like oh that's
the first time you've seen that yeah and
she was like I guess I've never see was
what so you how long do you sit there
and we're depends right just like how
long does it take you to goes I just sit
go I mean I could never read so some
people down I have my [ __ ] Scrabble
board in my bathroom I like I like to
really extended I mean those people of
probably healthier though did you sit
they I'm sure done you ever saved
something you're doing on your phone
like you're on your phone you're like
wait a minute I'm gonna [ __ ] in like 10
minutes
oh yeah they not do this now yes I'll
save my dick
I get lost on social media that's the
bad thing about these phones though
because you can with that and with games
you can go to [ __ ] pull up your phone
yeah be done [ __ ] for a while I mean
you're sitting there hoping more Duty
comes so you not just sit there on the
toilet like a [ __ ] idiot right crazy
you ever stand up and like all the blood
is gone from your legs and feet
no like you've been like leaning like
this in your thigh yeah until you stand
out or like you can't even move your
lower leg oh yeah yeah I've collapsed
you have it's a great feeling yeah yeah
great feeling I like a butt like a good
thing to put my feet up on I can't [ __ ]
what am I feeling you like a squatty
potty yeah I have to get one there great
now what do you do you are you using now
nothing now but I I forgot when I moved
I don't have one like a year I got oh
you used to have one ah what about in
your house do you have a day or a wash
light it's broken I Bob Kelly taught me
there's a heated seat toilet yeah and it
had a thing that would come out and that
thing's not working out I don't know who
to call should call a plumber
yeah plumber will be able to fix it okay
yeah I became upset we rented a house
that had one and then we bought our
house it became like an immediate
necessity once you have that in your yes
oh my god the warm seat and then that
[ __ ] a little nozzle that comes out
and shoots warm water into your [ __ ]
you know amazing yeah economically I
don't feel like I'm there yet but
hopefully after this contract I'll get
serious to put it in the contract yeah
bad idea
yeah Pavarotti had his own toilet logged
everywhere yeah fat ass yeah yeah he's
such a big guy you'd have his own toilet
put in how would they like they were
just brinch to all the toilet he's never
even yeah uh yeah we're in his hotels in
the hotels - he's Pavarotti
isn't that Pavarotti you put the [ __ ]
toilet how amazing the levels of Fame it
was like there was that we're way more
famous than your average citizen oh yeah
I mean like your average citizen it was
like oh whatever you guys are yeah this
and then like when you have some level
of fame and you start realizing how many
levels there are - oh yeah and that at
that level someone can be like make sure
you install a toilet
when I come to write and like cuz like
if I said that they'd be like are you
insane yeah I mean I've been walking to
be a picture of me with a hole in the
mouth [ __ ] but for some people they're
just like will concede to that point
where we can call the front desk and go
like could you bring up an extra pillow
and they're like yeah like well call
housekeeping right they might come by me
right he had a cry that would raise him
up to the stick he was so fat he had
something that like he had to walk a
bunch of steps that would like lift him
not a crane but he like one of those you
know like hydraulic yeah yeah Burt has
that I know what you're talking about
your own toilet I love that he had his
own time to him well maybe it was just a
seat I don't know I know that the Queen
that you know that's been a thing at
least for a long time kind of England
when she travels she doesn't sit on
anybody else's seat they always like
they put on a new toilet seat yeah yeah
yeah later toilet a seat so she's not
Pavarotti level yet she's not that's the
Queen of England right she brings a
regular chair redeeming yeah I guess I
guess what happens is part of the you
know the advance team that goes and sets
things up for the queen is like she's
not sitting where you just sat right
take a [ __ ] toilet yeah yes so there's
brand-new toilet seat yeah to screw on
you know you can unscrew the toilet yeah
yeah that's that's one of her perks her
shits must be oh just old lady ones a
lot of farting before dump she does a
lot of gay she probably takes liquidity
shits so you got a hope though with the
Royal Wedding there is so much that goes
into it that that doesn't fall under the
radar yeah because when they're sitting
there like oh and now they got to worry
about this markle's dad you know how he
can't go they got to go no you hear
about he was selling pictures to
paparazzi yeah he got caught of himself
really like he was please putting promo
stuff in his pen photos like he was he
organized with the paparazzi to take
photos of him hold it like with product
placement and he got paid like a hundred
thousand pounds and the royal family
found out and now he can't go to his
daughter's wedding he why he said that
he uninvited himself and I tend to
believe it that he was like there's no
way
don't embarrass my daughter I won't yeah
Wow but who knows maybe he'll go I hope
he goes I don't think I can't believe I
care
did they were they distant you mean it
did were they estranged oh no I mean he
was already in England he has to go is
it coming up I don't know
Saturday oh I didn't know it's on
Saturday morning he's gonna watch
oh no I will okay good I think you
should go but I mean with everything
they're worried about the dress they're
worried about this they're worried about
that thing at all these people coming
it's happening in a palace and they
still have to have a guy there that's
like and I got the toilet seat yeah I
got the Queen seat right does she have
her own room she goes to she must should
she ever own but is it like it wasn't
even she goes to the toilet her own
bathroom yeah did you leave if she was
nothing right here right now she she
would I think afterbuzz has an extra
toilet seat we chase the Queen stop how
good if she clogged the bowl she's so
properly clogged it she took a big kill
bosses [ __ ] it really wouldn't surprise
me if Kevin was like no and I also I do
have an extra treat in here just in case
the Queen comes by guys you don't know
you don't know she may I didn't know
that she had her own seat Pavarotti was
fat I mean there's a reason yeah I got a
big [ __ ] man especially I
watched some reality show he did where
he was like training people can you
imagine being so famous you can't you
too have hotels install your toilet and
they'll do it but you still do a reality
show well no but it was it you know it
was like America's Got Talent but pop
but for opera Sears so he would have you
come in and he was like watching him
understand the intricacies of what they
were doing wrong like they sound like
great singers to me but he was talking
in Italian and you like holy [ __ ] well
maybe was English was he able to find
the next great opera star I don't
remember it's just like these clips from
the 80s it was before a lot of these
show yeah but the fact that when you
when you what fascinates me there's
people who understand something that I
have no comprehension of and they
understand it's a different language
it's a but singing opera is so like I
would never know but he was knowing the
shape of the mouth has to be this and
you have to hold it it was actually
really interesting to watch yeah um you
know a whole bunch about chess right
you know technique I love I know it but
I can't I can't I can't employ it looks
like you ever beer I've been around
someone whose palate is so sophisticated
like a chef who you know they take it by
something they're like oh yeah we have
you know cinnamon rosemary what or like
right sommelier with wine you're like
they're so sharp in that one field that
they can pick it up from scent yes
saying how they documentary about
sommelier yeah yeah they're just like
studying for years and dudes and year
that [ __ ] is so crazy that they'll they
smell and and they go okay I'm I'm
sensing this is Spanish right they get
the giraffe this is a northeastern
region I'm set and and then they start
then they go to the it's got to be one
of these two vineyards I think it's
actually from this this year sip it
swirl it and they're like it is this and
they'll know the exact wine exactly what
year was and from from scent and taste I
mean I understand how you only wine
documentary I never watch is the one
who's ripping everybody off did you see
that one the Asian guy who is like
[ __ ] bootlegging all this wine it
looked real he was a master at making
these bottles look like real wine
bottles but they were all a [ __ ]
[ __ ] selling it was so great like
these [ __ ] spending ninety thousand
for a bottle of wine and [ __ ] oh my god
loved it
but guys like yeah these are my
collection they had experts go in people
really take wine to certs really
seriously I get annoyed with all those
documentaries of people taking things
too seriously like I watch the
Berenstain barista documentary do you
see that one they like it's again this
thing where they train all their
littering for years to pour cups of
coffee no I'd like to combine like so
there's the little foam swirl on top and
everything and like you go to this
convention where it's like an annual
convention of all the top baristas and
like the climax of the movie is like
she's sitting there and she's pouring
and a little bit spills out and
everybody cool after all these years of
training a little bit spilled out of the
top but she's not gonna be the top and
I'm just sitting there watching it and
going like even the top barista in the
country she's making like 14 bucks
what do you do we're still just making a
beverage that helps people [ __ ] job is
that's really what it is what what's the
what are you doing no it's I can't get
in I can't think of that seriously any
of those things I don't take what I do
that seriously right sometimes you you
can you see you know I don't know comics
can take it so seriously there have been
enough documentaries on comedy anymore
I'd love to know more about the process
I think well how do you write are you
right on stage or you a pen to paper guy
this would actually make a great podcast
if you guys ever thought of like a
comedian to a comedian just talking
about the form yeah you know I mean that
could be cool I think the document I'd
like to do is we get a comedian I don't
like we asked was process and then to
show us that then she begins writing you
take a piece of metal you break his
fingers that would be the most popular
podcast you have to keep tricking people
into doing it yeah this is the one they
break your fingers no no please start
your favorite joke right Emily doesn't
the people he doesn't like he really
likes you yeah just so you write the do
break your fingers yeah a piece of metal
ER from other episodes okay fine all
right Jesus
I did see a video of a guy having his
shins broken in a Brazilian Jail doing
with uh with a piece of metal a bunch of
prisoners they had the guy's leg they
stretched it out and they literally hit
him 20 times with a piece of metal
across his shin it's the worst thing
I've ever seen you do - sometimes I like
watching personally like alright so
actually one of the videos I'm most
obsessed with mm-hmm because I do like
watching I'd only watch people get hurt
I like watching people react to being
hurt right so like certain screams yeah
make me laugh like the woman when she
was like stomping on the grapes that old
news clip when she found went oh yeah
exactly exactly I lost the table yeah
yes yes you know so yeah yeah so
actually I was on the old show as a
guest with you and you guys played this
video that I have since played hundreds
of times for all types of people of this
car backing up into a garage somewhere
in Asia and it backs into a guy oh god
yeah and he's
hilarious scream that I just can't get
enough of and also the way that people
don't give a [ __ ] like that come into
frame like this dude you just got hit by
a car twice doesn't matter and people
like lean and they're like all right and
they just kind of walk away like dude
this guy's get hit by a [ __ ] no that
[ __ ] really makes me laugh right okay
but like I don't like watching you know
beheading things I've seen [ __ ] like
that that or like I really hate when you
see a like a an attack on the street and
someone's like head bounces off the comp
yeah right that [ __ ] I can't get into
those things do make you realize how
mortal you are though yeah like that
makes you realize how worth it is it
yeah like you know I mean like when you
see guys crushed in a bus that bus tires
you're like you know what I'm gonna
[ __ ] look both ways cuz I see what
that looks like it's awful it's awful
it's a real thing it's not like oh my
mom told me that I was six
- be careful you're like oh no I've seen
what that looks like when a guy survives
that it's that's terrible it's terrible
I'm gonna look both ways
I saw one recently was a fat guy on it's
like a double-decker tow truck you know
or like one of those were not tow but
when a transport truck that has cars
they bring me the dealership yeah yeah
and he's on the top level he's a big
dude he's a moving well the truck is
parked but no car starts to like roll
off of it no to get out of the way he
just jumps from that so it's probably I
don't know seven feet something like
that and he it's the ground he lets out
a screen that is I mean you can feel it
inside of you you know he's gonna be
fine I laugh really hard at that and my
wife got really stirred by it she can
upset with you for life yeah right they
made a funny noise yeah yeah it's a
funny noise no noise just makes me laugh
yeah I guess that it also is way
different you know when you know like if
it's you I'll be like oh [ __ ] like Sam
broke his leg or something right it's
but when it's the internet some random
noise right it's like no yeah I probably
feel the same way oh is Tom okay is Jim
okay but if it I don't know them yeah
I'm just difference does it make yeah
there's fun to watch somebody hurt
themselves you know they're gonna
but that that's a [ __ ] yeah watching
somebody and they feel stupid too
because the guy made the decision to
jump off a truck and then he hurt
himself so badly so part of it is I'm in
so much pain and another part of his why
did I just do that yeah you know like I
made a bad decision also maybe if I
wasn't so heavy I wouldn't have broken
my leg on it only if the guy moved at
all he might have been able to survive
that does not do anything big bodies on
twig wigs and I just broke right right
oh yeah he just looked up at the guy
with a camera he was like crazy scream
work at accidents always freak me out
like a lot of them are in Asia or a guy
will get his hand caught in a machine
where farm equipment falls on you or
explosions and they know you know what's
gonna come by the title of the video I
think man there's some [ __ ] [ __ ] jobs
out there yeah but every day you're at
work doing things that are that could
possibly rip a finger off yeah well if
you have a way I look at your wedding
ring and I've heard that people yeah yes
it's a serious risk your finger off with
a wedding ring it's a serious thing if I
worked in a warehouse or something where
it you ever see a woman people like a
shell falls on and kills a forklift
driver yeah like there are some really
hard jobs just things and I don't want
to do every day oh my god the world is
full of those jobs and I do feel like
it's good every once in a while cuz you
know we get so caught up in our business
with like shows material touring
specials and all this stuff and you can
really get like obsessed and lost in it
and then you see somebody doing one of
those [ __ ] jobs and if you're you
have like the right frame of mind in
that moment of the day where you're like
my [ __ ] is this it helps you with
gratitude to see somebody that's hurt
yeah yeah because I'm not hurt I
remember driving a forklift for this
copper company and the ramp we take it
was I had a boom on the front there was
20-foot copper tubes wrapped and it was
it was you'd pull on the back of flatbed
trucks and the the ramp was broken so
the left side of the ramp was good but
the right side of the ramp dipped and
like rusted out so literally I was
afraid every time I went up that I was
gonna back over the raw in and then just
fall off the dock and be paralyzed and
I'm like I'm just glad I have to do that
anymore yeah like I'm just glad I don't
have to worry about lining up my [ __ ]
forklift on the
other end of on the on the outside end
of a flatbed truck and possibly falling
off yeah and paralyzing my now you sit
here and talk I talk yeah and just joke
around exactly an [ __ ] I worked at
Smith and Hawking which is a lawn
furniture company
one time I scratched my arm with a hose
pot so I get it to hurt yeah I was
bleeding I had to wash it off and
everything there's a little scar on my
arm that's no joke look you can kind of
see it see it
still got it we should a little lower on
the wrist okay that yeah no I got it
it's right there yeah tattoos I do what
do you have I have a white zombie logo
here then I have Rob Zombie's autograph
here you have an autographed head I have
Jack White's autograph here you think so
would you get Ozzie I guess if you
wanted me to I guess I would I mean what
what level of love do you have for these
guys though I mean are these guys like
real heroes to you yeah London yet
deeply yeah especially had a point in my
life I mean right now yeah but when I
was in like high school going into
college you were high school was like I
loved Rob Zombie mm-hmm to the ends of
the earth and then all throughout
college I love Jack white to the ends of
the earth
so he's saving his other arm for Gary
Glitter yeah about John Cena I don't
know very good John Cena it's don't cold
I wouldn't say notice don't call the
Undertaker yeah we're probably good The
Undertaker Vince see so no disrespect
for the boss Vince McMahon is like a
person though yes he is like Jack White
Rob Zombie are like cow musicians
characters like the Undertaker is a
character so it's not like I'm
professing love for this would you ever
do that no Ozzie maybe well first your
Pryor is alive guys I love I'd have to
love you so much but I'm you really love
Ozzie I do he's my favorite personal
life but at this point this point I
wouldn't do that yeah I mean I I
wouldn't be too weird to ask him a sign
no no sign my [ __ ] arm I think it was
an [ __ ] yeah I think outside of my I
don't know if I was I don't know I would
get any more at this point I've signed
the guy's ass I gotta get attention he
did he showed me he had a good cheeks
I've signed my name if your uncle Paul
tattoo I've seen that's the ship tattoo
people send in ship Jefferson tattoos
I've seen a few I've I I've signed a few
marker like I'm gonna go to a tattoo
shop right now and then they'll send you
Mike you got my name autographed on you
but then somebody just did a portrait of
me on them
did that mean more well I just thought
it was my thought was just like you
can't possibly want that you shouldn't
be on it yeah yeah that guy's gonna
someday attack you with an accident well
that's way minutes on his thigh it's
huge I don't never signed an arm or
anything like that but I would ask you
and you too cuz you've signed I'm sorry
it's like no I'm not asking you to sign
my autograph no no I know both the I
don't need that do you want to autograph
a tattooed I'm gonna be great for the
show that was you got my name and I
promise to do it and didn't do it we're
gonna get each other about this yeah him
signs his name on your arm right at
marker mm-hmm and you let me tattoo it
all right perfect
I don't think we should be great it'll
be a grandpa it would be a great bit but
it's something like like even six months
from now I would explain it to somebody
and they go like they wouldn't be
laughing like oh that's a great bit
they'd be like just get it off Sully's
getting his tattoos take it off so you
got smackers all your honor so you can
do that yeah he is some of them very
painful to get tattoos you mean thats
what he said yeah you use laser beams so
it's cool cuz it kind of honoring your
coworker you know is that cool to you
for your co-workers Nate like do you
Burt tattoo is not my coworker that's
true
use your Pierre you both work in comedy
we're not talking up here's this guy you
go to work with every day every day
right
well better way to show solidarity is
contract time comes up make that part of
the contract give me a bad day and I
will get Jim's name doesn't make any
sense
do you when you sign a person's arm or
body parts not a lot of autographs
I'm sure you do do you is it implied
that they're gonna go get that tattooed
on because people were like oh my purse
them too when Jack white signs your arm
did you tell him you're gonna go get it
tattooed and I was like no but I figured
why else would he yeah at a certain
point when somebody goes hey will you
sign my body with this marker right if
it's not at it like a tit thing is you
of course it's own little fits a man but
yeah and he gives you a marker he's
probably getting a tattoo yeah that's
right he that's what I said I've never
actually
said I'm gonna go do this do you have
any not already I mean yeah yeah I think
you know you get to a certain age age
where it doesn't really make sense to
start right yeah I mean less I could I
could see myself you know I'm 39 in a
few years just being like alright ready
for my midlife crisis I'm just getting
something just getting your whole league
whole [ __ ] dragon on your butthole
new look I got a [ __ ] stamp
yeah my on my arm there you go part wire
yeah are you gonna remake all of Pamela
Anderson's tattoos will be funny
wouldn't it be amazing if Jim had all of
Pamela Anderson's tattoos yeah you
should Steve Oh does that I think for
Angelina Jolie he does yeah I wonder how
many tattoo artists right now would if
you went in there and go hey I wanted to
get barbed wire on my arm would just be
like yeah I'm sorry you have to find
somebody else yes like that everything
I've seen by getting something like
tribal you know am I on my own like a
Celtic Warrior yeah can you write
fearless in Chinese and yup thousand
dollars I got ten thousand there are
some real happy tattoos all right there
oh my god unless you're a [ __ ] Maori
oh yeah Oh in short no I don't mean like
Samoan tribal I mean like getting like
tribal bands and stuff yeah I mean
barbed wire I feel like there has to be
top of the list awful that's got to be
that's like the you know the guy that
gets his gold gym membership when he's
like ready to show these off I'm getting
[ __ ] barbed wire it means I'm barb
wire on me yeah this doesn't bother me
my sharp so Pam Anderson has that sheet
again she'd had a few years yeah that
for a long time he probably was somebody
who took it to you know new heights
right well yeah I try almost got my
buddy I went to his a bachelor party and
he was he was in the city and there in
like the village and stuff and he was
all [ __ ] up but he was drinking black
tooth grins I think those are what the
drink was and he was like obsessed with
it all night it's all he was talking
about and we walked by a tattoo place
know and I was like dude you need to get
a black tooth grande tattoo
usually I'll [ __ ] do it right now no
they go yes absolutely the school
teacher I was like yes a hundred percent
you need to get it on your arm
you
to walk into your wedding day like this
like you're lying again we went in and
the tattoo boys would not do it was
wrong yeah cuz he was because he was
drunk him because it was clearly a bad
idea but that's to say there are these
would you laugh at him though if he had
happened on his wedding every my
favorite thing in the world I would
invite him over all the time just to
look at it I would think it'd be the
benefits your friend there's nothing
better
right nothing better than a good friend
I wasn't himself I was prepared you get
one so that he would get one cuz I don't
care like it what difference does it
make I can't autographs on my arm with
who cares at this point
but for him he's like just a normal guy
in a schoolteacher it's got like a wife
and a kid like that what it didn't it
hurt your tattoos yeah I mean yeah like
yeah not like horrible no I hate what
would you need forget to get my name
tattooed on you like like an autograph I
don't know I mean what do you got to
offer you to be dead I mean it would
depend on what was on the table we made
contracts coming up just give me a
number do you want to pay me to get it
done right um I mean I would do it
easily for 25 grand 25 grand
yeah it's a lot it's there forever man
what size are we talking same size
disease same size I have to get it some
not on this arm though that'd be to not
pollute that arm yeah I probably get on
the other arm how about 25 grand but you
got to get me and Tom I'll chip in
twelve five for both of you
yeah not bigger but just on your arm
twelve five years you're much worse I
gotta tell you the why because I know it
like I really like like you I go to work
with you have a day your there's nothing
about you that's not just a guy to me
right I mean I guess I've known Tom you
would be worse because I see you every
day like Tom at least I don't see every
day so would starstruck and you every
guest we would have in studio would ask
that I show them I would you say that my
co-host looks up to me I would believe
twelve five no I wouldn't do both to
twenty five that's a lot that's a lot
man no if I thought yeah I know but I'm
offering you a lot I'm offering you a
piece of my body forever that's your
entire body's not worth 25,000
I would say I would do the 25 on the
condition mm-hmm that it's a little bit
larger than the other two okay and that
I want Jim and Mary Jane's name
underneath it I'm not doing that for 25
that's great right no I would need way
more than 25 for all those names a lot
of money man no I know but it's a lot of
names I'm having to sit and by the way
what it also is that money that you're
giving me is the tattoo budget coming
from that meaning I have to pay the guy
who does it know that oh that's separate
you take care of that sure how much to
get my name in red jumps out of yeah I
also want to phrase underneath my name
yeah what would you want the phrase
didn't I want it to be like is the
number one best my favorite comic ha ha
ha ha can I get that on my back yeah
okay that's because that's too much for
the arm that would look stupid
how much to get on your back the words
come here and are all pointed at your
heinie how are you spelling come see you
n-no I like your shoes no thanks man
what are those those are adidas peer
boosts right right so you get nice
they're the most [ __ ] comfortable
shoes I've ever worn Jim's been
struggling my shoes are cool they're
really horrible I've been trying to get
Jim New Balance everyone's been poking
fun of my old man like a single dad
that's just trying to give by are they
bad shoes those are not good
last I'm not that New Balance are all
bad those aren't great last time we yet
knew there are cool new balances there
are last time we were here they skipped
over though I thought these were cool
Jim was invited to a Maria Menounos his
celebrity house party with all these
famous people there yeah he wore those
yeah I got [ __ ] a boy nice Aziz house
they look horrible hey now you're
leaving right after the show right yep I
was supposed to take you sneaker
shopping while we were here we'll do a
back in New York ham oh you gotta come
back in a big apple me you and Troy okay
I want to go you're gonna point out some
cool [ __ ] to them yeah I'll get those
those adidas are nice yeah black I want
bucks what I want black shoes so you
you can wear with anything nobody
notices yeah yeah yeah but mine they
notice because they're awful but those
are cool we'll call her socks is it
black socks oh yeah yeah yeah I mean I
could definitely find some [ __ ] I
have ankle high socks yeah
I have a latent homosexual do you like
he like be I was wearing some air max
90s the other day yeah he liked those
that's the first time Jimmy's been like
okay I like those and they make those in
black I'd get a jump black shoes dude
give us some that with a dunk lows yeah
yeah he's also he worries he's got wide
feet the pure boost they're so
comfortable
yeah that's never Tom Price white figure
a wide man yeah what size nine and a
half
Jim wants to go on the complex show
sneaker shopping yeah you know but he
tried to go on did you yeah they
wouldn't take you I didn't hear back Wow
take me on something else when the Queen
young I don't [ __ ] know so I mean one
that gives you free shoes no but then
that's not the right one no I know right
no yeah Jim wants to go on that but he
wants to try on every pair and like make
sure you get one for the wide foot in it
right can I put an insert into this one
yeah
actually just go shoe shopping yeah
right yeah and make it like a real drag
you don't think the people who watch
that would enjoy my episode I don't
think so we got to wrap up this was fun
it was really fun time glad you came by
you can follow Tom Segura at Tom Segura
on Twitter and Instagram Segura Tom on
Instagram Segura Tom on Instagram and
now 17 or 18 year old British boy it
took Thomas abit okay so don't follow
that [ __ ] yeah and you can get all of
his dates there if he pays enough money
I'll get his dates tattooed onto my
forearm whoa about just the website then
and that because that way when your
dates change I'm still up to date yeah
so Tom co.com slash tour yeah well we
can talk about it I mean again now now
you're talking about advertising that is
pure advertiser so that's more money
yeah but the only person that sees is
your wife though if it's on my forearm
everybody's gonna see it I roll up my
sleeves like a month and people are
gonna ask alt like what's on your forum
and you'll be like I'm secure comm slash
to her he's actually really funny so
check him out
right and like there'd be like you'd
have you know people walking by studio
guests and be like what is that
musicians artists comes to go knock on
superstore this tour it's a comic he's
out in LA but he doesn't show sometimes
/ tour tour
yeah and then what would be great is it
if you changed it like you just change
your website just despite me / tour
dates yeah and I was like it's not that
anymore well this will get you a 4:40
message now
[Laughter]